he was the multi-talented logan  the maverick  [Music]  the one and the only floyd  [Applause]  mayweather  [Music]  and a half 189 and a half  [Music]  mayweather 1505  and there they are ladies and gentlemen  it's show time  [Music]  he don't know what to expect and this is  not the biggest fight of my life  this is the biggest part of his life  because he's got a lot on the line and  he got  everything to lose i'ma go in there have  fun if the fact that i'm even up here  proves this is a simulation  none of it's real the aliens are coming  in june just be ready  tomorrow i break the simulation and beat  the greatest boxer  in the history of the of the planet once  again i'm not worried about a hat  i don't worry about what nobody say one  thing i can do i can fight  i've been at the top level for 25 years  so i know what it takes  when it's a fight of this magnitude much  respect champ best of luck on sunday  thank you  [Music]  you